welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Anthony @g Avadi an agrarian Studies
Program fellow at the Macmillan Center
he is a historian of science and
technology with training in architecture
and cartography today we'll talk with
him about his award-winning first book
Ganges water machine designing new
India's ancient river it's the first
atlas that's been done on the basin in
more than half a century and based on a
decade of fieldwork and archival
research welcome professor at javadi
thank you for having me Maryland let's
start with an overview of your book tell
us about it
sure so the book is a history of the
Ganges River basin told through the
history of its infrastructure
particularly in terms of its
infrastructure going from canals to
privately-owned bore wells and how those
interface with growth in population
density and the capriciousness of the
monsoons so the book is really
structured in four parts the first part
is really a kind of survey of the Ganges
so why is the Ganges so important what
is its importance within the context of
India with respect to Hinduism with
respect to Empire and imperialism and
the and the kind of environmental
conditions of the basin the second part
is really about how this River Basin has
been transformed to one of those highly
engineered landscapes on the planet so
really how does the Ganges water machine
come about how does this landscape get
turned into a giant water machine from
the 19th century all the way up to the
20th century and the third part of the
book is looking at the decentralization
of water infrastructure that takes place
especially at the early during the early
20th century and explodes during the
second half of the 20th century and and
through today and then the fourth part
is what I call a dynamic Atlas which is
a company
of an atlas and an almanac where I'm not
just trying to map out space say as a
static condition of here's a building
here's a landscape but also how does
this landscape change periodically with
the monsoon so really mapping the
choreography of water and people bring
all of those infrastructural cultural
and environmental layers all together to
give a dynamic sense of the basin it
sounds like a huge undertaking and I'm
curious what led you to the project well
it's a I would say it's a mixture of
academic interest and autobiographical I
grew up not far from the Mississippi
River lived for a time in New Orleans
and also in Rome Italy and I just always
had a romance with rivers and cities and
I knew that I wanted after I graduated
from college to really study a river in
depth and a set of cities and so I was
scanning well what rivers and cities
have not really been looked at very
carefully and I came across the Ganges
and the Ganges River just blew me away
in terms of its population density we're
the most densely populated river basins
in the world agriculturally extremely
productive undergoes radical changes
every year with the monsoons and yet
hadn't been mapped in about half a
century and having just come out of
architecture school I wrote a Fulbright
proposal saying for me as an architect
it would be fascinating to map what is
this area look like how do people adapt
to the monsoons and how might we develop
new ways of visualizing this landscape
so that it's not just about words and
numbers but also giving a sense of
measure to the slow motion changes and
the fast pace changes that are happening
here so I wrote a Fulbright proposal
before Google Earth was launched to
undertake this kind of madcap adventure
where I said I had to go out and walk
the land and do my own surveying and
much to my surprise I got the Fulbright
to do it and I thought I could do it in
a year but it took me about ten years to
do the whole project so I am curious
during the landscape must change
dramatically during the monsoon season
so were you there during both during the
monsoon season and then not during the
monsoon season I'm curious about your
methodology about how that actually
work and also how much you know mile how
many miles is you cover and doing this
well so I was there for Mom soon
pre-monsoon post-monsoon so at the
Fulbright fellow I stayed one full year
and I really used that year as a as a
kind of datum to map out these changes
that happen in the basin so I would keep
going back to the same areas across the
across the River Basin to map it not
just cartographically but also
photographically so I would combine
cartography and photography together so
you could see both and more traditional
cartographic since how do rivers and
surface water bodies expand and contract
both horizontally and vertically but
also how do people change their habits
of living in these environments as they
change so definitely the monsoons in a
way we're almost like a kind of clock or
calendar that I used to measure and map
this space out over time and then I
ultimately went back and forth of course
of 10 years 23 times to do all of this
mapping and in terms of the area that I
covered I mean I walked and voted about
1800 kilometers of the length of the
river and then that's not just following
the line which of course zigzags a lot
but also crossing it because trying to
really understand not just the river is
to banks with water flowing in it but
really understanding the larger River
Basin or the watershed how that ties in
to the Himalayas how those Himalayan
rivers like the Ganges and the Yamuna
River are very much fed by the monsoons
so how does the monsoon not just water
this area but pull over a billion tons
of silt down the river basin every year
so really trying to map out at a kind of
almost global scale those weather
patterns all the way down to an urban
regional scale to even soil structures
them so I mean it just strikes me as a
huge undertaking I am curious how howdy
how do you measure the water itself I
mean so that's nice that's a great
question well you know I got to India
and I was hoping that I could find some
maps I thought okay I can't find any
maps here in the US Google Earth very
low resolution so it's hoping that we
there and I could find some apps but I
could never find and in fact when I
would ask are those oftentimes be asked
if I work for the CIA and of course I
said you know no I I did not that I
think somebody who worked for the CIA I
would say they did but I never got to
see any contemporary maps because never
really existed and them and the data on
water flow back when I first started
this work in 2005 with very scant from
the government so I really had to use
methods from geology and hydrology and
then also develop my own instruments and
techniques and guerilla tactics of
mapping the spaces and developing
instruments from mapping soils and their
movement across the basin and do you
have any idea of why no maps have been
made oh you know during the 50-year
period well you know in the book I
speculate as to why that might not be
the case and so the survey of India is
the government body that's supposed to
be mapping on these areas periodically
for the government but I speculated in
the book that maybe one of the reasons
they haven't mapped this area for such a
long time is it's so it's changing so
rapidly the monsoons DRAM dramatically
change it just every year in terms of
the landscape population growth is
extreme just in the state of Uttar
Pradesh that I lived in it's 200 million
people living in an area half the size
of California so it'd be the seventh
most populous country in the world
so traditions of cartography a
representation of these static maps fail
to capture the dynamism and and the
change that's happening in this
landscape so I suspect that's maybe why
they haven't Mack initial I'm kind of
tough to do yes I'm living target
exactly
okay I know you probably had several
adventures over the course of the decade
that you were working on this project so
give us some of the highlights tell us
some stories sure I mean I would say
some of the most amazing stories were
boating along the river the oftentimes
riding with boatman down the river and
various segments seeing freshwater
dolphins was quite amazing for someone
like me coming from the United States I
think kind of seeing a glacier lodged in
the side of the
Malia's and having this kind of
burnished Emerald City kind of hue
glowing about it from indirect sunlight
was really just kind of nothing sort of
extraordinary and I certainly had quite
a few adventures in terms of run-ins
with people probably the the most
colorful one was I was out mapping very
early on a canal that's said by the
Ganges and I was with a driver and we
were driving along on a certain point he
stopped he refused to go any further and
explain to me why that there were
dacquoise or bandits in the area so I
thinking that he was kind of just didn't
want to go any further I got out walked
a you know a kilometer or two and then
as I was getting ready to do a set of
photographs three women were approaching
me and I didn't think much of it but at
a certain point they whipped out machine
guns are together about you know my good
mattress remember so around me and I
dropped my camera put my hands up and I
you know still learning Hindi at the
time so the first thing that came out of
my mouth I said in Hindi your country is
very beautiful and they looked at each
other and looked at me and then they all
three started laughing and two of them
lower their guns and they were asking
what I was doing there and I explained I
was mapping the Ganges said that this
isn't began she said yes but this is a
Ganges water flowing through here and
they ultimately let me go I didn't know
what I think they didn't know what I was
doing there as much as I didn't know
what they were doing there so certainly
were the most colorful experiences that
I had very interesting in the beginning
of our conversation you were talking
about you know how the Ganges is
important to India let's talk about some
of those reasons
sure well certainly the Ganges of the
Ganga is very important to India in
terms of Hinduism it's a sacred River
some would describe it as a deity and
it's a sacred River that is marked that
has incredible terrestrial sites that
are imbued with celestial significance
which is to say that certain important
events have happened in these areas say
in the remind of the Romana of
Mahabharat but also there's a kind of
topographic monumentality that inscribes
significance to say where
two rivers meet at a confluence or a
kind of sacred site or river our city at
an auspicious bend in the river it's a
site that is inscribed with so many
meanings and layers and a kind of
religious and I would say a cultural
level and it's also a river that is
oftentimes identified as being very much
Indian and that millions of people
survive in terms of their water for for
drinking for agriculture for industry so
it often times I think both in India and
abroad
holds a certain privileged place within
the imagination of both of the Indians
and non-indians as to what constitutes
in a given that importance I know you
recently I think a year or so ago wrote
an op-ed that was in The New York Times
about the Ganges and how there is a
water crisis of shortage actually so can
you talk a little about you know what
the situation is today certainly so you
know that often New York Times is drawn
from part three of my book that really
looks at the rise of decentralization of
water infrastructure and one of the
things that I discovered from mapping
the ganges by footing by boat in the
hundreds of thousands and estimates run
as high as 20 million privately owned
bore wells or tube wells exist in the
basement and they're not just for
farming that we usually think of as
being so important for the Green
Revolution of the 60s and 70s but many
people living in cities draw up their
own groundwater instead of relying on
the municipality because the
municipality either can't provide enough
water or it's not clean or any number of
issues so many people take it upon
themselves almost kind of like
wildcatters to drill their own bore
wells and it's a completely unregulated
economy so there are many people that
are over drawing so the monsoons are not
able to replenish those aquifers fast
enough so there's this kind of tragedy
of the Commons where people are
extracting the resource faster than it
can be replenished and so in that op-ed
I described the scan geez water crisis
is really coming out of the the process
of decentralization of water
infrastructure and what do you think
needs to happen and India to prevent
this the shortage of water since
millions and millions of people depend
on it
so I think you know it would be very
hard to go out and literally map all of
those tube wells because one that's an
almost impossible task it's like trying
to plow the sea and also there are so
many people who don't want you to know
that I have a tube well so really what I
proposed in the op-ed in The New York
Times was developing models of
development for all new development that
happens that really takes into account
where your ground water comes from and
the amount of area that you leave open
for recharge of that aquifer so thinking
of planning not so much as being purely
in three dimensions but also taking into
account time so adding that fourth
dimension so how do we recharge
groundwater for them with waters from
the monsoons to support agriculture but
also just the incredible urban growth
that's happening all across India
exponential growth actually so where do
you see the Ganges in 50 years for
instance well as somebody who as a
historian I'm always wary of being a
futurist because I know how often
futurists are wrong so I I'm not going
to I guess give a sense of where we're I
imagine it could go but in an ideal
situation it would be great to see India
taking on the the water crises the
environmental changes along with the
population growth really experimenting
and thinking of it as a laboratory to
develop a new set of soft
infrastructures and by soft
infrastructures I mean infrastructures
that don't require a lot of electricity
or hard infrastructures like pipes but
instead say bioswales and wetlands that
really take into account and deal with
the dynamism of of the basin in terms of
the runoff of pollution into knowledge
our grains and developing economies
around those and also new planning
procedures now thinking of
infrastructure is being monofunctional
so not thinking of a canal is literally
just moving water but how does that tie
in to railways to roadways to
development so how do you laminate
infrastructures and not think of them as
being modified
I'm curious with the work that you've
done and since it is so new and nothing
else out there is like it I have you
contacted any of you know the
governmental officials in India to say
hey you know this is work that I've been
doing I mean are there any plans afoot
to try and lessen the effects of the
shortage of water in India today
there certainly are plans and the World
Bank has loaned India a billion and a
half dollars to clean up the gunk or the
Ganges River and that really requires
maps of the basin which you know hadn't
really been produced for a very long
time so I've met with members of the
government about the the maps that I've
developed and how those could be useful
for moving forward with some of their
plans of cleaning up the Ganga and and
really making it explicit not just in
what I say but in the maps that I show
how this is as much a kind of urban and
agricultural set of issues as it is a
kind of environmental remediation
program so it has to be a larger
synthetic project would be my argument
of taking into account all of these
other constituencies and conditions as
opposed to really just thinking about
how do you take the pollution out of the
watering and are they receptive to those
ideas they've definitely been very
receptive I think that it's always
tricky coming you know added from a long
long long term view versus the way in
which I think a lot of members of
government and politicians operate which
is in the you know in an election cycle
as opposed to five or ten year plan so I
think a lot of times there's in search
of a silver bullet that will fix these
things but it took a long time to get
the way that it has and I think it will
also take of course a long time to try
to make improvements to it so that might
happen in a piecemeal level but I'm
hopeful I remain hopeful that it might
be holistically tackled by the
government and and various
national and state government and also
non-government organization right
hopefully that will happen so while
you're here yeah I know you're working
on a project done does it tie into this
what what are your next steps definitely
so the work that I'm doing here at Yale
is working on my my next book and an
exhibition that looks at the history of
village India really from Independence
all the way through the kind of middle
to late period of the Cold War and I
came across a new village in India
because having walked so much of the
Ganges I was always amazed by the amount
of village just the actual density
villages that existed here and it's
oftentimes been historic sail'd projects
to develop villages and I was very
interested in how the issues surrounding
villages were very much tied to
environmental questions of how do you
develop better agriculture sanitation
how do you improve the larger
environment not just physically but also
socially and that was very much tied to
a lot of the work that I started to
study with the history of tubewells and
decentralization in India so my next
book is looking at the history of
decentralization and village India and
then a series of exhibitions that look
at the modes of trying to develop
pedagogy visual pedagogy for villagers
in India during the Cold War to try to
teach them or persuade them on how to
make improvements to their villages to
be part of a larger decentralized
nation-building project
excellent we will look forward to that
new book coming out okay thank you for
being here with us today thank you for
having me for more information about
professor at Giovanni and his work
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Eddie Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at you
[Music]